good morning John thanks for making an
animal sex week on a week when I have to
write a song tragedy of tragedies I had
to write a song about animal sex here it
goes we've been together through a girl
quite a while and I think might now I
know how to make you smile you've
evolutionary biology and the gift
adaptations are so sexy but I want to
teach you the realities of birds and
beasts we all know about your ass girl
then make me love them and have more sex
with each other than with the better
half and there is no better way to
destroy a mood than to make a tortoise
noise but I won't do that stuff just
loving is enough oh maybe there's a lot
of ways to make baby
and if it's right for us I was old but
maybe we could try a couple up see what
the fuss is all about it's just the
birds and the bees and the chimpanzees
and if things go right maybe you and me
done certainly you're cute girl but I'm
supposed to dolphin sex lasts just 20
seconds at the most but what I got is
pretty dull next to the amazing barnacle
their junk is 50 times bigger than their
body size
maila Clah fish gets completely screwed
proving sometimes sex sucks even for the
dude but the violence prize goes to the
flatworm using a sword like penis to
stab in its person uncomfortable world
but not for my girl oh baby there's a
lot of ways to make a baby anything to
read the Russ I was hoping maybe we
could try a couple uh see what the fuss
is all about it's just the birds and the
bees and the chimpanzees and if things
go right maybe you and me yeah if you're
right maybe you and me Oh if things are
right baby you and me yeah anything I
put that bit about the chimpanzees in
cuz I wanted to put some footage of
chimpanzees having sex but turns out
it's a little too much like people
having sex for me to be comfortable with
that was it creepy I don't it was a
little creepy let me know in the
comments if you thought it was creepy
speaking of asking and answering
questions I just started a new profile
at a new site called view comm it's V
y-o-u calm and I'm at view comm slash
Hank green and it's kind of cool and I
want to know what y'all think of it now
it's coming to time of the video where
we must face the unpleasant truth about
space pasta several people had excellent
calculations and no matter how people
did calculations several different ways
the unanimous responses that moon pasta
is much less efficient than Earth beef
my two favorite videos were Michael and
Bardot's and the dancing Hawks Michael
Bardo only calculated the getting of the
rocket to the moon and bringing it back
from the moon with the pasta on board
and that turned out to be something like
400 times more energy intensive than
growing a cap which honestly seems a
little low to me the dancing hawk on the
other hand figured out how much it would
take to get all of the supplies to the
moon necessary for building a farm there
and then getting the pasta back which if
it were done
turns out would be the most inefficient
endeavor in all of human history
according to the dancing hunks
calculations which seemed pretty sound
to me it's about six thousand five
hundred times less efficient to grow
moon pasta than Earth beef and now we
know and knowing is half the battle John
I will see you on Friday and this is the
new screen that we're thinking of having
at the end of all of our videos this
stuff on the left-hand side you will see
the shirts and the truth of fail that
stuff will change the previous next
video thing will always be there as well
to subscribe and the Twitter and the
Facebook things and I wanted to know
what everyone thought of that idea ok
that is all goodbye for real this time